[Music]  kendrick lamar and dave chappelle kick  off the 60th annual Grammy Awards in a  major way  [Music]  the 30 year old rapper performed a  medley of his songs on Sunday kicking  off his politically charged opening  number by performing xxx while  surrounded by dancers sporting military  carve and marching in front of an image  of the American flag Bono and the edge  made a quick appearance on stage right  before Lamarr transitioned into DNA then  this brief yet epic interruption by Dave  Chappelle the only thing we frankly were  watching a black man be honest America  is being honest black man in America  Lamar ended with a jaw-dropping  performance of his lyrics from J ROCs  Kings dead  [Music]  the number earned a standing ovation  from the audience  [Music]